on va revenir sur le début du débat et
c'est vrai que le générique donc marine
le pen commençait à parler regardez je
voudrais savoir si elle le savait avant
ou pas ça regardez on y va marine le pen
c'est vous qui avaient été tirés au sort
pour prendre la parole en premier
[Musique]
dans le monde mais les plus grands
atouts de la france c'est son peuple
marine le pen oserais-je alors que le
débat à peine commencé vous internautes
juste pour vous rappeler que nous
voulions avec la vous poser un anneau
dans les mêmes termes pour une durée
d'une minute trente la question suivante
qu'est ce qui nous empêche sera
évidemment pas de vous exprimer je veux
démarrer avant même jeu mais s'est
désamarrée ça la musique ne pouvait
reprendre ce crédit boussera 2011 j'en
avais enlevé les otages enlevés les
seconds j'en suis absolument en avril en
était à dire que le plus grand atout de
la france sinon quelle horreur ce
plateau de merde qu'ils ont fait mais
comment non mais comment on peut faire
aussi un générique aussi long mais
laissons rigoler mais wiki qui choisit
ça mais je me dis les mecs c'est le
moment le plus important en télé 2 6 1
quand les mecs font un générique de
merde qui dure deux heures ils sont même
pas capable d'arrêter le générique un
moment est de dire aux candidats ça va
être à vous le plateau c'est certain que
c'est une catastrophe le plateau mais on
se croirait sur une télé étudiante non
mais c'est quoi ça un mets qui a fait ça
mais c'est rien mais qu'on le trouve ça
mais ça donne un golem et c'est lui
qu'il faut mettre au chômage pendant
cinq ans sarah connais mais c'est une
over ont déconné mais comment on peut
faire ça mais je dis les choses il
franchement c'est quoi ça c'est quoi ça
après le générique deux heures le
générique est plus un générique et au
moins moi je vais du rondo veneziano
cette émission voilà j'avais des choses
mais le générique est pourri est ce
qu'elle savait que le générique allait
s'arrêter un moment parce que c'était ça
ça a duré trois minutes ça a duré trois
minutes elle avait pas forcément le
retour et puis surtout le lancement
normalement de se faisait au futur c'est
la marine le pen c'est vous qui allez
commencer dans un instant oui hélas
c'était marine le pen vous commencez non
gras on y va donc évidemment elle a cru
que c'était le signal nation s'est
adapté bon ça l'incident du direct
honnêtement on peut pas en vouloir à
jouer les deux profs six bonnes manches
on veut arriver aujourd'hui
leur dira à réunir moi j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] le tenir à [ __ ] non mais
juste ça te met pas dans de bonnes ça
vous met pas dans des bonnes conditions
tu démarres c'est comme un match de
tennis la série démarre on dit non
finalement on va mettre la baci plus
c'est c'est pas bien réagi franchement
elle a pris avec humour elle a relancé
je pense que ça n'a pas joué sur la
suite du débat et je pense que voilà il
n'y a pas eu de y'a pas le plus
implications que ça de florence pisani
non ça c'est lamentable c'est au fond à
l'image de tout ce qu on a huit c'est à
dire des candidats dans des boîtes de
conserves c'était absolument pas du tout
valorisant pour des gens qui ont quand
même prétendent aux fonctions suprêmes
de les y aurait de l'argent là dessus un
sens inouï sort commencé à dresser la
feuille commence à coûter 300 400 vélos
à ses rues ses métiers sur wat a coûté
au moins 800 mille ha oui il le raconte
castaldi règle en soit c'est lé prix
cantabrie qui loue des bateaux à 300
millions
donc pas possible avec lorient en ce
moment comment on peut faire ça en tout
cas l'entourage des candidats qui a
quand même beaucoup cherché à cadenasser
l'exercice aurait dû je crois dire que
ça ne leur convenait pas que ça n'était
pas un écrin suffisamment valorisant un
double jeu qui le chiffre annoncé a
coûté 1 million il est aussi redoutable
et d'eugenio total ils sont
comme ces france 2 et tf1 qui habite en
face à 100 mais je n'arrive pas comme le
support je dis moi le moi
comment vous allez trouver le plateau
d'el haouz moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
le fond je peux comprendre qu'on
commente le décor mais leur fou le fond
ça le fond du débat le fond du débat
mais on fait de la télévision acct e
mans la télévision est important c'est
d'abord ce convoi avant ce qu'on entend
et ça d'ailleurs je crois pas que les
candidats hier les biens saisis cet
exercice il est d'ailleurs très datée
très désuet pas du tout adapté à l'ère
tik tok que l'on connaît j'ai pas bien
compris pourquoi on proposait sa aux
français le score d'audience mais aussi
de l'histoire de ce qu'on leur a
proposées parce que nous n'avions pas du
tout exister il ya pas eu de relance pas
de vérification
encore très long même le début de
l'émission tu dois avoir un mec qui te
dit att sur les événements des ddc cinq
ans j'adore gilles bouleau
il va animer la foire à la saucisse
c'est pareil antoine navet pardon en
mauvaise santé et la syrie bien sûr
c'est de la télévision a oui mais sur la
forme compte mais même à la télévision
il ya du fond mais c'est pas à vous le
professionnel que je vais là où il n'y a
pas un contenu c zéro vous fait que
dalle mais justement voilà je
m'intéresse c'est le contenu c'est pas
moi qui suis un petit un petit 10 6 pour
un lecteur de jacques pilhan et qui va
vous démentir sur le fait que la forme
et la stratégie médiatique est important
mais cela dit il n'ya pas de stratégie
médiatique avec du maquillage qui sert
une des idées qui ne sont pas des idées
son contenu la forme et ne vous permet
pas de cassure sur le sur le fond alors
on va revenir sur le fond de deux
petites minutes 5 minutes par sujets
sains sorte quoi cinq minutes chacun
particulier excusez moi si vous en avez
pensé ou non mais je pense que c'est un
équilibre très compliqué il fallait est
très encadrée c'est à dire que pour la
première fois pour chaque thème il y
avait un temps précis d'habitude c'est
un chronomètre pour l'ensemble de
l'émission asséné dans mes erreurs ça
mes amis n'ont pas permis d'éviter les
des bords de la mer
las on s'est fait chier non en tant que
téléspectateur parce que c'était cadré
allez on a parlé de ça on va pas dire il
fallait me mettre un chronomètre toutes
les missions au moins y avait des
débordements nous ce qu'on veut c'est
des petites vous savez pourquoi cyril si
je vais me permettre la dernière fois
les deux sujets pratiquement les plus
importants étaient à la fin du débat on
était en tête des bords qu'ils ont été
bâclés en trois minutes chacun et donc
il ya une frustration dément ce qu'ont
voulu les rédactions des deux chaînes
ces deux paliers en fait à ce problème
l'un des seuls à en pleurer dix ans
l'important c'était pas corrigé juste
mais je vais vous dire la vérité
aujourd'hui est et ses salles énormes
erreurs et je le dis à eduardo et je
vous le dis pour moi l'énorme erreur qui
a été fait hier soir d'ailleurs on
trouvait pas un mec qui a dit que
c'était exceptionnel hier soir ils vont
le trouver il m'appelle enfin
joli nom mais c'était pourquoi c'était
nul à chier je vous le dis c'est pas à
cause des candidats ou moins
l'organisation les amis danzé dans des
boîtes à 5 minutes il voir sujet ce
qu'on veut les gens ce qu'ils veulent
voir sur ce débat là les programmes de
marine le pen et d'emmanuel macron ils
les ont entendus sur france 2 ils les
ont entendus dans face à baba ils les
ont entendus sur françois ils les ont
entendus sur bfm i les ondes le pouvoir
d'achat on sait très bien ce qu'il va
dire marine le pen ce que va dire
emmanuel macron c'est ce qu'ils vont
dire aussi sur la retraite on sait
exactement on sait ce qu'ils vont dire
sur les crises internationales ce qu'on
veut c'est des petites phrases c'est des
échanges ces voix on va voter pour un
homme pour une personne on va pas voter
le programme on le connaît
c'est ce qu'on a c'est sûr prenez vous
ce qu'on veut aussi c'est la politique
de temps en temps mais je ne pouvais pas
croire pendant trois mois c'est un
problème si l'évolution de notre société
je veux dire vous votre votre métier il
est très différent mais en plus vous
êtes capable d'intégrer la politique à
l'intérieur d'une d'une émission qui
fait le spectacle et du divertissement
il ya des moments dans la vie dans la
vie d'un pays il ya la guerre je
rappelle où le sérieux du politique
revient et pardon les robes les jeux
barbon
doit privilégier le fond et moi je veux
bien qu'on passe trois heures à débattre
des deux heures et demie de ce débat
mais ce qui compte aussi pour les
français c'est qu'ils puissent se faire
une idée je n'ai rien contre le
spectacle mais le spectacle c'est pas là
mais l'éthique ce qui va se passer
dimanche est un enjeu très très sérieux
nation continue avec la république où on
va vers le nationalisme c'est aussi ça
vous arrive à l'excès de langage qui
vient d'être prononcée c'est le cas l'ex
de la tradition politique dont nous faut
donner le fond c'est le national est un
penseur le fond c'est vraiment très
important l'élection présidentielle je
crois que on le dit toujours si la
rencontre entre un peuple et un homme et
une femme et c'est ça et puis donc il y
avait deux enjeux définir le programme
d'ailleurs il ya eu beaucoup de ce fait
que news 1 / programme de marine le pen
j'ai vu que monsieur darmanin disait
qu'elle allait faire mourir les pauvres
j'ai vu lu dans l'ope ce qu'on allait
lancer la bombe atomique sur la chine
donc c'était pas mal finalement de
revenir sur la réalité du programme mais
bien sûr qu'il fallait ça les revenus
ont fait connaissance avec un homme et
une femme on voit qu'ils sont réellement
et je crois franchement que là dessus il
hier eh ben les gens ont compris ils ont
compris que marine le pen était
quelqu'un de calme stoïque sereine je
pense qu'ils ont senti un petit peu
d'arrogance parfois un petit peu de
mépris marine
faire des bureaux native de bilzen
klein marine le pen je le rappelle celle
ci est très intéressante on va pas
mettre des policiers pour surveiller qui
porte le voile donc ça c'est ce qu'a dit
emmanuel macron mais trop timidement
marine le pen a répondu vous l'avez bien
fait pour les masques en fait elle a des
tentatives de punch line mais
malheureusement elles n'ont pas pris
c'est dante affirmations étaient trop
timides ils ont essayé hier monsieur
mais ils ont pas réussi et du coup il
fait rien cela qu'on aurait dégénéré
monsieur le président la france avec des
punchline mais non mais
je comprends tout à fait ce que dit et
ce qu'on veut tous les programmes on va
les voir mais pourtant qu'est ce qu'on
retient des grands débats présidentiels
c'est ce qu'on retient de mitterrand
rappelle moi je ne suis plus le jeu des
oui je ne savais pas être premier
ministre
on retient de ce qu'on retient de de
sarkozy reconnaît mme royal à la
présidence sur quoi françois hollande
soit président c'est notre vie
collective aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
retient habiba
je suis pas du tout je pense qu'on a on
retient deux attitudes honnêtement eu
des attitudes oui mais c'est important
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui se disent
est ce que je vais voter pour emmanuel
macron marine le pen alors que c'est pas
mon premier choix c'est ça le deuxième
tour et notamment des gens qui viennent
de la france insoumise ou d'ailleurs
pour qui ces idées sont un peu éloignés
et honnêtement moi je vous le dis comme
je le pense j'ai été en tant que
téléspectateur dans le car régie choqué
choqué par l'attitude du président de la
république la manière dont il se tenait
sur son siège un peu comme s'il me
disait bon je suis en train de passer un
exercice obligé tout ça ça m'ennuie
profondément je suis président de la
république avis votre élection elle
m'ennuie passons ce cap est pas sans lui
vite et je pense que c'est un signal
pour une france qui a vécu les gilet
jaune gravement durement pour des
français qui ont vécu la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat une violence verbale des
insultes à répétition on a vu hier que
le président ne changeraient pas et je
pense que rien que pour ça ce débat il a
été utile eduardo je suis venu cyril ici
ce soir ils vont me bats pour une seule
chose j'avais envie de vous parler de
manière un peu plus personnel la traîne
moi je suis pas né français
je suis arrivé en france à l'âge de 10
ans je suis un immigré comme des
millions et des millions de français
j'ai été naturalisé à l'âge de 22 ans
et tout ce que j'ai appris c'est grâce
aux maîtresses et aux maîtres d'école de
la république à mes enseignantes et des
enseignants et professeurs j'ai grandi
dans la banlieue française à créteil j
effet de ma classe clean là où les
enfants non francophones apprenez
apprendre apprendre le français on dit
venez avec nous viens avec nous on va
faire de toi un petit français comme les
autres on va t'apprendre notre langue et
en sept langues aujourd'hui je vous dis
une chose simple et je veux dire aux
jeunes et à tous vos téléspectateurs
tout ce que j'ai appris de la france ce
pays issus de l'humanisme des lumières
qui est la république qui est fille de
l'humanisme et des lumières tout ce que
j'ai appris de la france grâce aux
maîtres de l'école française sait que le
chemin voulue par le pen n'est pas le
bon pour la france si je peux dire ça
aujourd'hui vous l'avez le nationalisme
français n'est pas la solution pour la
république c'est parce que je les ai
appris grâce à mes maîtres français ils
ont fait de moi un frein un français
parmi les français j'ai été fabriqués
par l'ins ans alors et la france
n'aurait dépensé sur les jeunes et le
dimanche on n'est pas non mais là il
dira non non on n'est pas l'agresseur
qui doit à présent que ce soir on est ce
chemin on est juste un mot devant vous
l'avez trouvé vous même alors marine le
pen écoutez moi je pense qu'on a fait
passer le message ceux qui croyaient un
petit peu exactement ce qu'on vient
d'entendre attention marine le pen elle
aime pas les étrangers attention qu est
ce qui va se passer demain ils vont être
mangés les enfants parce que média pas
vous n'y aura plus la république y aura
plus de 2 et bien ils ont compris hier
que marine le pen était une femme
raisonnable calme sereine qu'elle
n'était ferme évidemment sur ces
principes qu'elle avait un programme qui
avait été travaillé et qu'elle était
prête à être présidente de la république
après chacun fera son choix mais au
moins sur ce point la syrie contre elle
croit qu'elle a cassé cette image que
certains essayé du deux mois jeu blanc
mais on a vu leur entraînement vous
pouvez commander vu quoi vous j'étais en
train de me rendais c'est en cela que le
pays n'était pas un peu gilbert montagné
s'il est vraiment vu
image franchement où sun life des
tropiques mais vous vous regretterez
tout de suite sereinement se dire en
regardant ce qu'on a vu hier qu'on a
intéressé les français que l'on a réussi
à parler aux français qui n'avaient pas
voté pour l'un ou pour l'autre qui s'est
dit alors qu'ils se sont durablement
éloigné des hommes c'est à eux qu'il
fallait parler hier ils sont pas
véritablement monté sur le ring le
président a été étonnamment offensif
elle a été étonnamment défensives elles
étaient systématiquement fait piéger par
l'aspect techno elle a voulu montrer
qu'elle était compétente et elle a
systématiquement glisser sur une peau de
banane que lui lui tendait sans jamais
réussir à parler au coeur des français
je crois que c'est une difficulté ils
ont sont piégés enfermés dans des débats
de chiffres totalement inintéressant
pareil juste un exemple très sain mais
ils ont passé leur temps à expliquer
pouvoir d'achat avait augmenté moi
j'imagine est deux secondes les gens qui
n'avaient pas voté ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre qui ont qui n'arrive pas du tout
à finir enfin moi qui entendent ces
deux-là dire que le pouvoir d'achat
augmenter pendant ma rivale a bien dit
qu'il avait laissé un marine le pen
arrive yannick il avait baissé mais je
pense que la politique a déjà souffert
de ces chiffres je suis pas je suis
gilbert montagné mais vous aviez
sûrement des boules quies quand vous
écoutez là j'aimerais mais moi je suis
pas d'accord avec vous vraiment pas une
fois encore tous les sujets qui ont été
abordés emmanuel macron attaquez vous
avez raison marine le pen mais ce qui
veut dire que c'est son programme qui a
été au coeur du débat on n'a parlé que
de son programme ça tombe bien manuel
makonda n'a pas part à la retraite à 65
ans et ça il est paradoxalement c'est
une victoire notre projet non on va pas
bien
c'est une vision non je veux juste
revenir sur le débat quand vous l'avez
préparer marine le pen vous avez fait
des face à face quant à l'or il y avait
plusieurs équipes c'est vous qui faisiez
manuel mental non pas du tout il avait
pas quelqu'un qui faisait emmanuel
macron elle a préparé pendant d'abord
depuis cinq ans bien sûr 1 sont
programmés pendant un jour et demi les
différents arguments elle a bien revu
tous les éléments du programme cognac
deux heures deux heures et demie de
débat c'est peut-être un peu l'ont
d'ailleurs mais on pouvait pas tout voir
donc elle a sélectionné des points
importants il ya eu effectivement un peu
d'aidé ping pong avec des mélanges je
vais vous dire moi j'étais très déçu sur
les 2 1 oui le dit à bord les deux c'est
quand tu as deux minutes à la fin pour
parler aux français je te mets face à la
caméra tu connais ton texte par coeur et
enchaîne emmanuel macron j'ai trouvé que
voilà il s'est dit bon de façon voilà je
décide emmanuel macron j'avais
l'impression que c'était ma fille quand
elle part à contrôler tu acquiers fois
je connais voilà tu avais très bien au
bac c'est l'arrivée l'arrivée l'a fait
bon bah voilà c'était sympa ici un bon
bah super pas avoir un président comme
vote 6 voix si ils sont sur pétain
marine le pen est sympa et marine le pen
excusez moi alors je vous dis toujours
dit il elle peut pas lire ces fiches sur
les deux dernières minutes
mais non mais juste sur le débat ce
qu'on a retenu non mais tu vois c'est
pour çà a vu une seule chose at en 2000
parce que je suis sûre ça comment et
pourquoi le lycée fiches sur les deux
dernières minutes marine le pen elle
doit s'adresser aux français et montagne
raison simple je vous expliquer je pense
que qu'est-ce que prince harry s'est
dégagé
le je vais donner quand même mon
sentiment je crois que les français ont
compris et les sondages le montrent les
quasiment 60% des français qui ont été
convaincues par emmanuel macron et 40
dons qui ont été nos régions va leur
revenir ce matin le pen je crois que
s'il ya une chose qui s'est dégagée du
débat hier c'est utile c'est qu'il y en
a un qui est compétent et une autre est
incompétente et d'ailleurs je voudrais
quand même posé une question il ya eu
cette formule que je vous réagissiez la
tue les deux il ya des personnes sur dix
la suffisance et l'insuffisant très
insuffisant vous avez entendu sept mois
je connais emmanuel macron d'une arrière
d'arrogant et je peux vous dire que ça
c'est faux il est comme il est il est
nature il est authentique et je pense
qu'ils ont commencé hier il sait
maîtriser comme ma fille tu maîtrises et
pour ne pas tomber dangereux ocassion je
veux pas m ce qu'il peut ressentir quand
il ya quelqu'un d'extrême droite en face
de lui je vais vous dire un truc simple
parce qu'à un moment donné mais il a été
très sympa revenir sain
par poutine est tout moi j'ai envie de
poser une question simple auditeur
demandez vous pourquoi vladimir poutine
a choisi de jouer la carte marine le pen
pour la soutenir en france comme il
l'avait fait pour soutenir train peau
aux états unis qui emballe anglais
pourquoi monsieur poutine choisirait ait
choisi marine le pen pour une raison
simple le but de monsieur poutine étant
d'affaiblir leur ordinateur en france
d'affaiblir la france de fragmenter la
france il choisissait comme nicolas a
choisi c'est le diable comme sur poutine
au foie
mais je vous dis je suis en france et
reste je vous dis oh semblait comme
nicolas sarkozy ou pas au passage mais
voilà et est ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que si poutine qui est un
tacticien redoutable et dangereux s'il
choisit le pen comme confirmés at c'est
parce qu'il sait que
les français ils veulent affaiblir la
france de quoi parle d eduardo et
laurent jacoby excusez moi je suis
choquée par la manière dont vous
exprimer sur ce débat franchement brillé
tout le monde pour pas dire emmerder
personne n'a regardé le risque des nuits
de la vieille politique vers dijon c'est
pas rien mais vous vous avez perdu la
demi heure où les jeunes bien sûr tous
les gens vous avez perdu tout le monde
dans le débat et vous avez l'air de
trouver que votre candidat était bon
qu'il y avait du contenu tu sais pas je
me suis jacobellis ce débat honnêtement
moi en tant que téléspectateurs
intéressés par la politique c'est un
fiasco c'est un fiasco pour les deux
pour la politique et vous vous auto
congratuler nord-est c'était bien et
tout ça
parce que c'est pas du tout ce que je
souhaite c'est que je vais dire vrai que
c'est complètement entouré par là dedans
moi y'a quelque chose et je vais vous
décevoir qui m'a plu c'est que je trouve
que le ton même s'ils étaient parfois
très offensif était quand même assez
cordiale oui scandait qu'on a pu aller
dans le fond de chaque sujet c'est
peut-être ce qui vous enverrez parce que
parfois c'était un petit mois j'ai dû
donner en dur des débats entre des taux
a eu des débats où c'était le concours
de la punchline c'était le ring de boxe
je suis pas sûr que ça soit à l'honneur
de la politique et que ça n'explique pas
une part tant d'abstentions en revanche
là où je vous rejoins c'est que
l'exercice est un peu datés c'est un peu
conventionnelles je vous promets je ne
passe pas la brosse à reluire non mais
je trouve que quand vous inviter marine
le pen sur un plateau et que vous lui
posez les questions avec les mots qu
aurait utilisé les gens sur le marché là
et bien là là elle sort les tripes là
elle explique son programme parce que
vous parlez
meyer est réelle le pen pour moi c'est
ça oui alors honnêtement franchement est
ce que c'est le genre dans les manuels
mâcon si marine le pen est apparu après
le ballon
c'est comme l'allié comme non on n'est
pas là pour distribuer
leurs voix mais ça c'est autre chose
non mais quand j'étais en 74 les mégots
ça soit on a regardé moi je ris je vais
être honnête quand il a fallu préparer
face à baron disais mais c'est un ovni
quand même politique et comment on va
gérer ça et en fait on l'a pas gérée
elle a été spontanée j'espère vous
l'avez ressenti nous on a vraiment
mérité qui est pas un face à baba
deuxième tour voire emmanuel marchand a
pas voulu se frotter aux infirmières aux
policiers etc mais on l'a regretté parce
que ça c'est du réel ça c'est du vrai et
ça c'est de la télé moderne non je pense
qu'il faut pas renoncer à l'idée oui je
pense que c'est un moment pense qu'il
faut changer avant il faut changer le
format